カルマの流れがね 一旦もうそこでストップしちゃったんですね
だからストップになったことはありがたいことで
その先生はもう予定通りには死ななかったんだから
もうずっと生きてるんだから
だからってその先生 そのホプキンさんがもうものすごく元気で
我々と同じく贅沢しながら生きているかというと
それはできない 今も指二本しか動かない
で なんとか栄養を口でご飯入れちゃったらなんとか食べられる
それだけです そこはもうどうしようもないんです
本人頑張って自分が早く死ぬことを止めてもらったんだけど
それで幸福か不幸かっていうのはまた決められないんです
やっぱりその先生幸福だと
仏教からちょっとわからないっていう
もしそんな生き方続くのは幸福かと
もしその人が素晴らしい生活をしていたんだから
すごい我慢強いんです
ものすごいわがままで
もう怒りっぽいで だから見えるでしょ
過去のカルマ そんなにもういいことをしてないと性格
過去の癖が見えちゃうんですね
大らかで楽しいっていう性格じゃないんですね
だからもうカルマから見ればもうまるっきり見えちゃうしね
たまたまこの頭が良くできただけのことでね
だから頭がいいことと仏教の智慧の次元
また違いますからね まあそれはそれで
ですから このもしかすると
その先生に早くも死んで新しい次元で新しい人生始めた生き方始めた方がより幸福かもしれませんし
あまりもカルマが強いんだから
ずっと長い間ここで苦しんでくださいということになっている可能性もある
ですから ただ寿命を延びることはいいという一概には言えません
幸福な人の寿命が延びるならば
それはもう生き延びてよかったという感じだったら
それはそれで大変いいことで
生き延びたことは生き延びたんだけど
もう何のこともないんだというならばね
例えばね いろんなところ
がんになったところで
腎臓も取り出したりして
肺も取り出したり 腸も全部なくなったりして
それでもう単なる肉の塊がなんとか生きているんだで
よかったですね 手術が大成功して
こう言えるでしょうかね
その場合は 医者は手術は大成功と言う
それは手術は大成功ですけど
人の場合はどうですかと
医者の手術大成功っていうのは
この決まってるプログラムで取り出す部分がちゃんと取り出して
全部縫って終わったところでも人が生きていると
いわゆる死なないうちにこちらで仕事終わったっていうことは
仕事の成功率なんです
成功します それで週間後死んじゃったら
それはもう自分に関係ない
手術の原因で死んだならば
別に自分が責任持ちますけどね
例えば多量に出血したりとかね
それは医者の責任で で
他の病気があったりして
その人は傷痕はなかなか繋げないとかね
それはちょっと見失ったとか
それだったら医者の責任になるんだけど
一応手術は最後のあのプラスターですか
それ貼るとこまで行って
それから意識戻るか待っているんですね
戻った そうっていうのはOK
だからそれはこの まあ手術成功に関係
すいませんだけど この人としてはどうかなとね
手術後幸福か不幸かと
手術後は幸福だったら
まあ幸福であるし 不幸だったら別にそれは悪いカルマの延長だけなんですね
ですから やっぱり仏教から見ればね
自分が本当に手術までしていろんなことをして延命するべきかないかと自分では判断できます
延命してもらったところで
よりこの人生は楽しめる
よりではなくて まあいくらかもう楽に生きていられるんだと
もうあと一年 二年でも生き延びた方がいいと思いますよというくらいの何かあるならば
まあ延命してもいいし
まあどうでもいいだろう
でも幸福なことにならないと思ったならば
まあいいですよと 私は自然に死にますよと決めた方がいいんですね
もうやりそこなかった
いろんな仕事終わったりとかね
もうちょっと子供はもうちょっとしっかりするまでは
まあ自分がもうちょっと生きたいなと思ったら
自分としてはまあ生き延びてもらって
その間では子供をしっかりするとこまでしてあげたと
そうすると気持ちとしては別に苦しいかもしれませんだけど
本人の気持ちとしては幸福なんですね
ああ よかったと これで安心して死ねるんだという気持ちになりますから
実際に生き方は苦しいか苦しくないかではなくて
気持ちとして幸福かないかと
例えば子育てっていうのは何のいいこともないんです
すごい苦しいんです でも
気持ちとしてはすごい幸福なんです
夜寝ないで もうね もう起こされるは
もうわがまま言う いろいろあるでしょうに
ですから自分が睡眠不足で
それでももう子供育てることは
育てる本人にとっては幸福なんですね
ですから それは幸福です
別に問題ないんです 気持ちの問題なんです
ですから延命の場合も
やっぱり自分が気持ちとして幸福だったら延命してもいいし
自分の気持ちから見れば早く逝っちゃった方がいいなと思ったら
例えば自分の子供たちやら孫たちは全然言うことを聞いてくれないとかね
わがままで薄気勝手だと
至っても喧嘩ばっかりですよと
早く出た方がいいやと
この連中からと思ったら
もう早く消えた方がね
その人にとっては幸福ですね
気持ちとしては まあそういう世界で
何といいますか 殺生心というのは理門であって
場所に門がないんだけど
心は自分で生まれる 自分で生まれる
そこは過去の何か 過去の何か捕まって
それによって生まれる
ですから 仏教の世界では
こういう輪廻信じている仏教の世界ではね
とにかく人の最後になってくると
とにかくいつでも気持ちよくするようにと
楽しくなるようにとか
いいこと もうとにかく心明るくしておくんですね
そこでもういろんなその人やったいいこととかね
思い出してあげたりする
大体病人だから文句言ったりするでしょ
もうなんで私はこういう
なんであなたはというと
もう看病する人々はね
今おばあちゃんそう言ったっても
昔はね こういうことをしたでしょうとかね
こんなすごい立派なことをやったんではないかとかね
いつでもそういうふうに
この心を明るい状態にしておくことにはもう必死になってるんですね
で 例えばまあ自分の国だったら
もう大体お寺に行って修行したりするんだから
もう動けなくなった ものすごくばあちゃんって文句を言うんです
もう寝たきりになっちゃったら
一番文句言うのは もう満月にはお寺に行けなくなっちゃったと
それで子供たちにまで怒っちゃうんです
それでまあ子供たちはどうしようもないんだからね
でまあそれでまあ大はっきりと言うのも本人の前で
もうただしゃべるんだよ
お母さんがね 元気な時はもう本当に家のことまで忘れて
もう修行に行ったりしたんだからとか
何とか言うんですね それで本人に聞こえるんですね
今はもうこんな状態だから行けないんだけどね
もし立ち上がったらすぐ飛び出すでしょうとか
そう言っちゃうと 本人なるほど
私は今ちょっと行けないだけであって
歩けたら私もいいことをするもんだと
すごく気持ちが明るくなっちゃうんですね
そういう人々はもう死ぬ時はもう阿弥陀様から見れば確実にいいところにお生まれ変われる
決してお化けになっては出てこない
だから自分の国はこういう輪廻転生を信じているんだけど
お化けのケースというのはもうほとんどゼロと等しいんです
お化けが出たり 幽霊出たっていうことはない
で もしかすると幽霊ってのは実際する現象であるならばないことの気持ちは分かります
なぜならば もう死ぬっていうのを知ってるんだからね
死んでからのここら辺ね
このうろうろはしたくないでしょうね
せっかく死んじゃったんだから
いいところに行きたいんだと
天国の話とかね 散々聞いてるんだから
やっぱりそちらに行きたかっですから
この旅する気持ちはよく作ってあげるんです
仏教ではこの巡礼というかね
それも一つの仏教の基本的な考え方で
人は一箇所に留まるもんじゃないんだと
私はこの家で死にそうと
そんなもうけしからんな考え方を持ってはいけないんです
どこで死んだっていいんじゃないかと
行きたいところに行ってとか
行ってだけれど 行って遊ぶところに行ったっても欲ばっかしだから
聖地を巡礼するとかね
そういうふうに歩いたりすると
我が家っていうのは消えちゃうんです
そのその場所がもう気持ちよくいることになっちゃう
もう一時的な一日 二日
三日の滞在かもしれませんだけど
そこで食事を作ったり
ご飯をそこで食べてシャワーを浴びたりして
ちゃんと生きてるんです
じゃあ出発しましょう
次の場所に出発して そちらの聖地をお参りするとかね
自分の国の人々は インドに行く場合は
日本人は二週間 もう最高でも二週間でしょ
僕はだいたい一番短いのは一ヶ月間の計画なんです
複数だったら三ヶ月間の計画でインドに行くんです
隣だからいつでも行けるんだけど
この巡礼に行く場合は
もう三ヶ月間計画で行くんです
だからそこでも家も忘れて向こうで死んでもいいやという覚悟を決めて
で 食べ物は体に合わない
いいんじゃないか それでもとかね
天気はまあそれでいいんじゃないか
そこで死んじゃってもとか
で そのある一箇所に行ったら
例えばお釈迦様が悟り開いたところに行ったら
そこでどこかで泊まって
一週間ぐらい泊まって瞑想するは
八戒を受けてずっと一週間お釈迦様悟り開いたところで修行するんだっていうことやって
そこで食事を自分で作って
お金がないんだだからね
で 自分で作って食べて
みんなと仲良くね そこでそこら辺
なんとなく自分の家になっちゃうんですね
それからまたそこの場所を離れて
じゃあお釈迦様は最初の説法をしたところに行こうと
そこまで行くと そこで三ヶ月間かけてもう巡礼して気持ちよく帰ると
そうすると自分の我が家という感覚がもうなんとなく消えちゃうんですね
それは死ぬ人にとってはすごい最高な幸福になっちゃうんですね
あ この人間は捨てたくないとかね
となっちゃったらもう餓鬼道に落ちちゃうし
私はこの家で死にたいと言っちゃうと
まあ落ちそうで死んだければそれはそこらしいことですけどね
余計なところで気持ちが落ち着かないところに死ぬよりは
落ち着くところに死ぬこともいいんだけどね
気持ちのいいところでみんなに愛されて
それもいいんですけどね
ですから とにかくこの旅する気持ちですか
我々はどうせ旅人だから
いいところに生まれ変わるためには
もう旅する気持ちはもう徹底しておかないと
一時的にいるだけですよと
この世の中 ちょっとこの短時間の滞在だと
ほんの短時間の滞在だと思っちゃえば
もう心がすぐ離れることできるんですね
ですから そこでそういう人々もいいところに生まれ変わることできるし
ですから この一番この心はいつでも明るくしておくことと
もう病気になってきて
もうどんどん見えてくると
自分のもう先が もうとことんもういいことをした方がいいんですね
いいことを思ったり 考えたり
やったりとか で そういうこともしない時は
大体この最後に この心が死ぬ時は体が弱い
当然ですから 自分の体の感覚は時々失っちゃうんですね
なんか何て言いますか
どんな状態ですかね なんか体がここにあるんだけど
心はここにいない状態になっちゃうんですね
何か意識がない状態に
その時はそういう人々は幻覚の世界に入っちゃうんですね
で また戻ってまた人と喋ったりする
まだ喋ってる途中で またなんかぼけーっとなんか抜けちゃうんですね
抜けちゃって また意識が戻ってまた喋ったりするとか
それは大体死ぬ時は大体結構ある現象なんですね
あの抜ける瞬間で幻覚の世界に入っちゃうんですね
で 本人がいろんなものを見たり聞いたりするんです
その時は そこで本人が自分がちょっと実際世界から離れたとわからないんです
わからないんだから 次に周りにいる看病してる人々と喋るんですね
あの人はこう言ったんだけどとか
でもその人ここにいないでしょとか
看病する人はおばあちゃん何言ってるの？その人今ここにいないんですよとか言うんだけど
そう言う必要ないんです
そういう人をおばあちゃんがちゃんと見たんだからね
幻覚の世界 その幻覚っていうのは
幻覚といっても この自分のカルマのカルマかカルマの結果か
次の生まれとこうかね
そこの何か特色なんですね
それによってあの決勝心が生まれちゃうんです
だから死ぬ時はいろいろ幻覚を見たり見たりすると
そのどんな幻覚かと真面目に聞いてみれば
どこに生まれ変われるかとわかるんです
あれはちょっとおばあちゃんがおかしいとかそう思うんじゃなくて
おばあちゃんおかしいじゃなくて
おばあちゃんに見えるもの
聞こえるものを言ってるんだから
おかしいということ自体おかしいんです
例えば我々正気の人間も麻薬なんか使ったところで幻覚を起こしちゃうでしょうに
それをあなたおかしいとではなくて
本人にはそういう幻覚を起こしますからしょうがないんです
で なんで麻薬を使う人々はずっと使いますかというと
いろんな楽しい幻覚とか生まれるんで
その時本当に楽しいんです
だから楽しくなって何が悪いかと思って
次にまた使ってしまっちゃうんです
それで別に人は楽しくなるのは悪くはないんだから
だからもうなかなかやめられなくなっちゃうんですね
だから言い方が悪いだけ
楽しくなるのはいいんだけど
たった一回 二回 十回楽しくなって死ぬのはもったいないんだと
ですから 浅く長く楽しみなさいと
深く短くじゃなくて 一週間だけ楽しんで死ぬんじゃなくて
ちょっとゆっくりと 自分の財産は一日で使う気ったら楽しいかもしれませんだけど
それからひどい目に遭いますからね
ですから まあということで教えてあげればやめる可能性はありますけど
とにかく ですから この決勝心生まれる時は過去生でやったこと
この死ぬ前の生でやったこととか
もっと遠い昔 過去生でやったこととか
あるいはカルマの何かの現象か何か出てきて
それによって決勝心が生まれる
それでその人は次の生をそこで決まってしまう
で 死ぬ前にそれいつでも変更できます
なぜならば この最後の瞬間は肝心なんです
ですから いくら死にかけている人にいろんな悪い現象が幻覚が起こしたりすると
聞いたらひどい幻覚だと
戦うことやら もういろんなもう餓鬼道の幻覚なんか思われてきたら
やっぱり叱ってでもね
なんでそんなこととか何とか言ってね
もっと面白いことを考えようとかね
面白いことを教えてあげたりとかね
それは変えてあげることはできます
でもずっと教育上はね
そういう考え方がないともう無理なんですね
ですから もういくら最後にも直せるのは
やっぱりずっとそういう心はね
正す方法で生きてきた人々にはその特権がありますけどね
例えばいくら仏教で修行していたっても
死にかけた瞬間に腹が立って嫌になってものすごい心が悪くなるかもしれませんよ
それは危ないんです でも
その人は今まで修行してきたんだから
そういう特権があるんですね
その時 誰かが思い出してあげる
あんたこういうことを聞いていたんではないかと
そんなくだらないことを考えないで
天界なことでも考えなさいと
なんで今更悪いことを考えるんですかとと言って
もうこれは情けないんだと
なんとか起こっちゃったら
本人がまた配度が戻って
もう機嫌が直っちゃいます
それはできます だからずっとこの清らかな心をね
間違いながらでも頑張っている人々には
死ぬ時はこのいいところに行こうという選択はなんとかできる可能性はあります
そんなことをまるっきり無関心で生きてていい人は
もう食うことしか能がないんだからね
普通の人っていうのは仕事して金儲けで
とにかくそれは仏教用語では食うこと
しかないんだからね その人にとってはちょっと難しいかもしれません
天国があるんだと言ったってわかってないしね
いいところあるんだと言ったってわかってないし
まあそこでまあこの門に生まれませんだけど
そういう対象を取って
あの 結正信が生まれる
それでその だいたいまあそんな説明してもそこら辺
ページが少ない それで十九番目で
この一つだけ対象する取る心と
五つの対象を取る心と
もうたくさん対象する心と分けているんですね
そこでこのげんのびせ心の五識
十識ですね それは対象一つで決まっていて
それからこの異界という三つの心があるんですね
両重心と随道心でしょうか
異界は三つですからね
あ 五門因典と二つの両重心
十八の中に入っているんです
その三つは五つの対象を取るんです
あの欲界の残りの心は全部
全ての欲界の対象を取るんだと
で まあそんなにまあそんなに明確に
まあ大したことないんで
そんなに難しいことでもないんです
アクサラニチェーバニャーナヴィッパユッタカーマーチャジャワナニテロークットラワジュサッパラナ
そこでこの次の行で八十二ページで不善心とチプソーオーの欲界即行心という心二重ですね
この即行心というのは
このただまあただの善心なんです
これから何です まあ即行で言っちゃいますけどね
出世間を除いた一切の所縁を所縁とすると
それちょっと覚えておいた方がいいんですね
で 不善心が十二あります
それから大心の中に善心八があるんです
それ足しちゃったら二十なんです
この即行心っていうのは善心です
それで覚えておいてください
善心と不善心は即行心と呼ぶんです
その十二の不善心と八の善心
その二十が まあまたちょっと違う
取り方違う あの即行心は全部善心だけじゃなくて
唯識心も即行するんです
ですから全部十六でやって
そこからこのチヒソーは取るんです
まあ明確にします この善心八の中で四つは智慧はない
チヒソー で 唯識心の八の中でも四つには智慧がない
だから智慧がない 四つ四つ足して八
それから不善心十二 その二十
その二十には出世間を体験できないんだと
それだけのことを言ってるんです
不善心にはできないのは当たり前なんです
で 善心でも智慧がなければ涅槃は体験できない
涅槃という状態を体験できない
智慧が確実に必要ということを言いかがっているだけ
で まあまたいろいろ説明しなくちゃいけないところあるんだけど
難しいんだからやりましょう
チソーの欲界心と第五善と
いわゆる神通心との五神は阿羅漢果を除いた一切所縁する
まあ当たり前のことを言ってますけど
で 智慧の心の場合は まあ欲界心ですね
で 欲界心ではこの智慧の心が
まあまた八ですね その心にはこの阿羅漢
道阿羅漢かは体現できないんだと
まあ自分にはちょっと上の状態だから体現できないということだけ言ってるし
第五禅というのはこの神通力作ることなんですね
あの第五番目の禅定に入った人に神通力はできるんです
この神通力っていうのは
もうなんか催し物みたいな働きで
あの これやりたいという気持ちで
気持ちで心を統一して
その禅定に入っちゃうんですね
入ったらそれでその仕事を行う
起きるんです 思ったこと
それだけでその力が抜けちゃうんです
ですから 他の何もできないんですね
ですから 神通力の心っていうのは全く仏教では評価してないんです
例えばこのマイクロフォンを消したいと思ったら
物理的に合理的にはできるものじゃなくて
神通力でこの第五番目の禅定に入って消してくれと意思表示をするんです
で その でも時間も決められるし
そこでもうその時間 そのマイクロフォンは消えちゃうんです
取っても取れませんし
見える見えないだけじゃなくて
触っても触れないし 消すっていうことだから
で その決まった時間が抜けちゃったら
またその場所に現れる
それだけのこと それであの禅定の力も終わりと
また他のことをやりたければ
また他 またその同じ禅定に入らなくちゃいけない
ですからもう もうなんかバカバカらしい
だから神通力はもう他心術とかね
まあ役に立つ時ありますけどね
一般的にはこのみんな好きがっているこの神通力っていうのは
この一番レベルの低い神通力なんです
このいろんなものを変化する
ものを移動する ものを透視する
ものを通っていくとかね
そういうのはもう一番レベルの低い神通力で
何の役にも立たない それより仏教でいくらか評価しているのは
自分の過去を見られる神通力
いくらでも自分の過去を見られる
人の過去を見られると
それから心を読めると
それはもう役に立つんですね
智慧に で だといっても
これみんなにはできないんですね
ですから これ作ろうと思ったらすごい苦労しなくちゃいけない
で 自然に備わっている人々が
その能力が その瞑想してもいいし
もう自然にそういう能力
可能性ない人々はもうやめた方が
諦めた方がいい あってもなくてもどうでもいいこと
自然に なんと例えば音楽に自然に能力ある人が音楽を習うたびにみるみるうちに上達しちゃうし
その人たち別に苦痛ではないんです
能力がないのに音楽勉強
習う人が毎日訓練しなくちゃいけない
演奏会やるたびにもう必死になって練習しなくちゃいけない
それで演奏中でもなんとかどうかで間違ったりするし
それですっごく神経質になったり
俺だったらいい加減やめた方がいいしね
軽々くできる人が ふざけながらもものすごく演奏できる人もいるんだからね
遊びながらふざけながらもうもうなんかできるだけその人やればいいんじゃないかと
俺も俺もやらなくちゃってこと必要じゃないし
もう自然に音が出る人は歌えればいいし
もう音痴な人はもう半年間
一年間ね 音声の訓練して訓練して
もうやっと一曲歌えるようになったって言ったっても
もうもともとやめた方が楽なのにね
やっと一曲歌えるようになったって聞く人は別にだからといってすごいと思うわけじゃないし
だからもう上手に歌える人はもうもうもうなんかいい加減に鼻歌したってものすごい綺麗なんですね
ものすごいこの歌手能力ある人がたまになんかくだらなく鼻で音出したりするでしょ
僕はたまにそういう聞いたことあるんですね
それでもすごいなと 思いますけど
でもですから やっぱり人相力の世界でも能力ある人はやりやってもいいんだけど
他の人はやる必要ないし
能力ある人には瞑想途中でそれ見えてきますね
自然に じゃあだからその心には大体この
この欲界のこれには阿羅漢では阿羅漢以下は体験
体験を通してできないという
で その章はそこら辺に終わりましょう
で これはもうそれから八十五ページの方がいいと思いますけど
で あ ワットはこの前説明しましたね
八十五ページの七番目に書いてある二十二のワット
ワットっていうのはまた場所という意味で
心が生まれる場所ということで
ここ六つ考えているんですね
チャックソタガニジワカヤハダヤと
そこで僕は説明してたのは
このハダヤっていうのはこの心臓だと拠点じゃなくて
注釈書で説明しているんだけど
お釈迦様は場所は決まってない
お釈迦様の拠点では場所を決まってないんだと
ですから心が生まれる場所はもう死んだよと言ってるだけで
うまく逃げてるんだと
で 注釈書ではこの心臓だと言ってるだけのことです
そこで二十三は大事なんです
カーマローケサッバーニピラバンテ
カーマローカっていうのはこの我々生きてる世界ですね
我々生きてる世界で 生命にはこのゲンリービーセッシンイーは六つも得られるんです
例えば人間には六つもあるんですね
心が生まれる場所 ですから
結構心が生まれることできるんですね
そこでルーパローケ ルーパローケというのは色界
梵天なんです 梵天になったところで
ちょっと違うんです 何がないんですかね
鼻など鼻と舌と体の三つがないんだと
いわゆる色界の梵天にはこの香りは嗅げない
香りはわからない それから味もわからない
それから体で触れてもわからない
なんかすごい違う生命なんです
で 味がわからないということは
別に味が必要なのは食べるためなんです
で ご飯食べない ご飯ではなくて栄養は取らない
で 鼻も栄養の資源ですけど
別にもう香りを嗅いで認識を刺激しようということはいらないし
ですから体で触って体を触ってもわからないということは
こんな触れる体は持てないって持ってない
その代わりにあるのは音は感じるんです
なんとなく音だけ感じられる生命なんです
それから目があるんです
眼識 ですから光も感じる
光と音だけ感じる世界なんですね
なんかすごい原始みたいな原始的なレベルの生命なんですけど
この原始という意味はこの存在の以前の状態なんです
ですからすごい長生きできるんです
減少化してないんです
音と光だけの世界 そこに心がちゃんとあるんです
考えたりはするんです
考えるために情報は音と光だけで十分です
で 私たちにとったっても音と光でものすごいほとんど知識そこでできてるでしょうに
言葉は全部そうでしょうに
まあ今日思い出した例なんですけど
人間っていうのは あの
ちょっとした赤ちゃん見たらどうで
ああ可愛いと言うでしょ
そこで三歳ぐらいの子供見たら
ああ可愛いと言うんですね
その子は十歳になったら
ああ可愛いですねと言うんです
そこで二十歳ぐらいになったっても可愛いと言うんです
そこで八十歳になったおばあちゃんが
五十歳の自分の息子がそれでも可愛いと言うでしょうに
言葉ただ可愛いだけということ
まるっきり同じですかね
同じじゃないんです 赤ちゃん見ると我々の感情と
歩いてる子供見るとの感情と
二十歳の青年見る時の感情が随分違うでしょうに
でも言葉では可愛いという言葉しか出てこない
ですから あの まあ言葉足らないと
そこで味の場合も 何食べてもみんなたった一つのこと
美味しいと だからはっきり言えと
もう全部同じ味かとは
みそ汁食べてもらって美味しいですと
おにぎり食べても美味しいですと
じゃあこのプリン食べてみたら
これ美味しいですと じゃあ三つ同じ味ですかね
全く味が三つなのに それでも言葉ない
だから美味しいと言うんですね
ですから この まあそこら辺わかってますか？でも我々は目で見るもの
耳で聞くことに対しては
いろんな言葉使ってるんですね
ですから この人間にとっても
我々の生命の もう八十パーセント以上
目と耳の情報で生きてるんです
目と耳と意識の情報で
で ですから この それだけになっちゃったら梵天なんですね
体と関係ないんだと そこで無色界になったら
それもなくなっちゃう
耳の情報も いわゆる光の情報も
音の情報も取れない ただ意だけ
ということは 無色界になったら
他の他の生命に その生命とコンタクトは取れないんです
コンタクトするメディア
媒体がないんですね 音で
ね 信号を出すか 光で信号を出すか
何とかないと あるいは電波信号にしたって物質でしょうに
それはどこかに触れて感動しなきゃ
それで心しかないんですね
だから場所はないんです
物質はまるっきりない
無色界では 全く物質ないんだから空間は要りません
だから我々にとってはどこにいるかとまるっきり言えない
どこにという言葉自体おかしいんです
どこにもいないだけでいるんです
心としてはあるんです
いるんじゃなくてあるんです
それが無色界なんです
無色界になったら 例えば人が瞑想して瞑想して
もう色界まで飛び出しちゃって
無色界の戦場に入っちゃったら
死んじゃったらその人はこれっきりでもうこの世の中の誰とももうコンタクトなし
そこで意識のみだから
今でも我々の心は妄想するといくらでも妄想できるでしょ
いくらでも何時間 何週間
何年でもできるですよね
だから心には自分だけ回転始めたら無制限に回転できるんです
だから無色界の梵天が
梵天はこの宇宙が消えてもいるんです
ビッグバンであろうが
ビッグクランチであろうが
もう関係ない もうどこにもいるわけじゃないんだから
あるのみだから ですから
この宇宙の破壊はもう何億回も体験
もう過ぎ去っても そこでもう意識だけ回転しながらいるんです
だからそこら辺は永遠だと
この ある聖者たちが誤解していたんです
お釈迦様が出会った時代のね
普通の宗教ではね そこまで誰も言ってないんだけどね
ちょっとした瞑想して
ちょっとした何か光感じた
ちょっと体からちょっと離れたような感じ
それだけでみんな梵我一如になったとかって言うんだけどね
そんなもんじゃないんだけどね
体は完全に消えた状態で
それで心のみ存在している状態は
心にも現象を受けていない状態は無色界だからね
で そこでまあ宇宙のね
宇宙全体のね 破壊はもう何億回受けたって向こうはもう何のことなく存在する
こっちと関係ないんだから
それでもやがてエネルギーは消える
妄想はいくらでも 妄想してはいるわけじゃないんだけど
心はただ自己回転しているだけで
それでもやがてそのエネルギーは消える
消えたらどんどんレベルが
この波が大きくなってきて
この色界 無色界の違う四つ
四段階だから 三段 四段階目から三段階になって
三から二になって 二から一になったりはする
そこで一瞬荒波をできたりする
そこで消えて消えちゃう
消えて物質作っちゃう
で 物質作ったっていうことは
他のところで生まれ変わったということなんです
まあほとんどの場合は
無色界の梵天は人間にいきなり生まれ変われません
生まれ変わったって大変です
生きていられませんだから
物質とも関係なく もう無制限に
無限大生きていたんだから
生命 生活できない ですからもう無色界の下へ行ったりとか
あるいは色界の梵天に行ったりはするんです
そこからじわじわと堕落すると人間に戻る可能性はありますけど
そこら辺はぐるぐるぐる
そうしかできないんです
こっち来たって 例えば急に梵天から人間界に生まれたら
ほとんど人間と生活できないんです
この梵天から落ちたらば
もう心は常に瞑想状態知ってるんですね
禅定状態 無意識の中に
だから落ち着きが欲しいということでずっといるんですね
そうするとこの騒がしい世界
すごく嫌になっちゃうんですね
だから大体一番うるさいのはお母さんでしょうね
赤ちゃんにとっては もうしゃべるわ
しゃべるわ 止まることなくしゃべるでしょ
あれは本能でやってますけどね
それでこの世の中のことを教えてあげてるんですね
子供言うことをまた繰り返して言ったりとかね
いろんなことをやってますからね
ああいうことでは嫌になっちゃうんですね
赤ちゃんが 普通の赤ちゃんだったら
母親のあんな意味のないあんな言葉というのはすごく聞きたがっちゃうんです
それを聞くと落ち着くんだけど
梵天から帰っちゃったら
もううるさい 放っておいてくれって状態になっちゃうんですね
だからすごく育てにくい
あまり感激しない ゲラゲラ絶対笑わない
何を いないいないばあなんか言ったらもうバカ野郎と思ってしまう
何やってるんですかって
いい加減にしろという感じになっちゃうんです
まあめったにないんだけどね
でもたまにはいるんですね
ですから そういう人々はもう早くもこの
だから世の中の食べて楽しむ
異性と仲良くして楽しむとか
これ一つも楽しくない
うるさいだけ だからそういう人々はもう過酷に出家するしか
もう生きたければ道がないんです
なかなか合わなくて まあそういうことで
天界から降りる人々っていうのはね
まあその人々もあまりこの世の中気に入らないんです
天界にいたんだから すごいもう楽に生活していたんだからね
ですから そういう人々は
この ものすごくきちんと堂々たる姿で
もうとことん贅沢の状況を作って
もう生きていようとは努力する
いろいろありますけどね
いろんなことを言ったらちょっと危ないんだから
そこら辺でやめます もうちょっと説明しちゃったら
自分たちがどこから来たかということは
なんだか自分でわかる可能性はありますから
で もうちょっと説明しちゃったら
自分たちがどこから来たかということは
なんだか自分でわかる可能性はありますから
で で ここで言ったのは
この無色界の人々には眼耳鼻舌身意
五つもない それだけ で
次の説明はわざわざしなくたっても同じことの繰り返し
一応それでその章が終わります
であのリーディサンガっていう六番目
六章は 四章ですね そこになると
結構今までの説明したことはもう簡単にわかります
で ここで今日の勉強会はそれで終了します
[背景で椅子が動く音]